[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
a key decision to protect the identity
of the jury which will judge r
b artist r kelly plus a win for a black
lives matter organizer
at the supreme court and a developer has
big plans for jeffrey epstein's florida
mansion
also he reached rock boston
closing arguments in a triple murder a
baseball bat is the weapon
a former pro player is the defendant
there's absolutely no
motive long crime daily covers court
cases from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to law on crime
daily i'm erin keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin a federal
judge has ordered an anonymous jury in
the trial of r kelly
the r b artist seen here at an illinois
state court hearing
faces federal sex trafficking and
racketeering counts in new york
that's where a federal judge has ordered
the anonymous jury which
she says is appropriate the judge lists
the serious nature of the charges the
defendant's history of obstructing the
process
the potential for juror intimidation and
intense media interest as reasons why an
anonymous jury is necessary
prosecutors have alleged that kelly and
his associates persuaded several people
to lie during a 2008 state court case in
illinois
and that kelly even told an associate to
contact
a juror in that case brian and terry are
here now along with criminal defense
attorney linda kenny baden
terry let's start with you i usually see
anonymous juries
in cases that involve drug cartels mafia
cases
gang violence cases does r kelly belong
in a similar category
you know i think every case has to be
decided separately but if
anybody should be in this category i do
think it's r kelly
he's been you know convicted or at least
he has been accused
multiple times before and if in fact he
did say that someone you know during his
earlier trial
uh should be saying that he is a good
guy and if in fact he did persuade
multiple people to give false testimony
then i think this is the perfect case
and i think judge donnelly made the
right decision here
linda kenny baden the defense says it
cannot adequately conduct war dear
questioning of jurors
without knowing who they are that at
least seems like a legitimate complaint
from the perspective
of due process of law do you agree well
yeah i've actually been to this
process or non-process i'd like to call
it in the phil spector case where the
judge decided there
that the jurors had to be anonymous now
when you're representing a client and
you're trying to pick the jury that is
going to have
the most honest opinion of your client
it'd be nice to know a little thing
about the jury
like where do they work you don't even
necessarily have to know their names
but you know there's some things that
defensive attorneys can do
to get a fair trial for their client and
one of the things is
is like uh sean's to see who these
people
are so brian do you often see requests
like this
do prosecutors just reserve them for
high profile people or or what's the
parameters here
so i've never personally seen this type
of request unlike linda kenny baden
i i've done attempted murder cases where
there are allegations
of witness tampering and that never
happened so i've never seen this
personally i've seen it just like our
viewers it's only in high profile cases
so lindy how do you try to actually seat
a jury then with these restrictions
well you try to let the judge give you
jury questionnaires that are so in-depth
that you know exactly what the
profession is their education is
etc etc so that you could develop a
profile for your jury
uh consultant to go over with you and
then you rate them based on the
questionnaires
and wait until they get into court
that's the best you can do but you can't
do anything to see if they're in
bankruptcy if they've ever had a law
case
if they've ever had a legal case if
they've never been you can't do any of
that background work
and without all that background work you
may wind up potentially linda with a
juror who
isn't even qualified to serve us or
stealth juror
who has made comments especially
nowadays in social media
if you don't know who their media
profile is
yeah a lot of questions for r kelly's
defense attorneys but that's the
decision from the judge and not a
mystery to prevent any tampering
attorneys for kyle rittenhouse are
working to raise millions of dollars to
post his bail
written house is charged in wisconsin
with murdering two men during protests
surrounding the police shooting
of jacob blake in august the 17 year old
is charged as an adult
and he's being held on a 2 million bond
one of his lawyers lynn wood tweeted
that they've already raised more than a
million dollars and that they need about
six hundred thousand dollars more
woods said that there isn't an iota of
evidence against rittenhouse
and that the teen was attacked while
trying to help people
a win at the u.s supreme court for the
organizer of a black lives matter
protest
law enforce brian buckmeyer explains
brian how'd the case come about
erin the whole thing started in
louisiana when someone threw a rock or
a piece of concrete during a black lives
matter protest for alton sterling
the object hit the officer who suffered
a brain injury and lost several teeth
the police officer decided to sue but
part of the issue is that no one knows
exactly who threw the object so the
officer named d-ray
mekinson as a defendant mckenson helped
organize the protest
and the lawsuit claimed that he should
be held liable for the officer's
injuries
a lower court of appeals agreed but the
u.s supreme court did not the supreme
court sent the case
back to lower case with instructions
that louisiana state court first apply
state law
to the question of mackinson's liability
before they got involved
the supreme court questioned but
ultimately sidestepped
whether holding makkinson liable would
have serious effects on the first
amendment
thanks for the update brian a developer
is buying sex offender jeffrey epstein's
mansion
in palm beach florida terry austin is
here now with
what he plans to do with that property
terry
well it turns out the developer wants to
demolish the 22 million dollar property
epstein was accused of luring young
girls to the property
and sexually assaulting them he died by
suicide in jail in new york city last
year
developer todd michael glaser plans to
build something new on the lot
he told the wall street journal that
palm beach is going to be
very happy that epstein's mansion will
soon be gone
glazer declined comment when we reached
out to him today
thanks terry a state highway patrol
report says south dakota's attorney
general was distracted when he hit and
killed a man
walking on a highway in september but
the report doesn't say
what distracted the a.g jason roundsburg
initially said he thought he hid a deer
but found a human body when he went to
check the scene the next day
fifty-five-year-old joseph beaver was
the man roundsburg killed
rossberg told the 911 dispatcher
whatever he hit was
in the middle of the road but a state
report says beaver was walking
on the shoulder of the road and still
ahead here on law and crime daily the
trial of a minor league baseball player
accused of triple murder
but first a look at a prosecutor's
decision not to retry
michael skakel for the killing of martha
moxley in 1975.
skakel's cousin robert f kennedy jr with
more on the infamous case including
skakel's explanation for why his dna was
at the scene
[Music]
[Music]
let's take a closer look now at a
decision by a connecticut prosecutor to
refuse to retry a convicted killer a
second time
after the state supreme court threw out
his original conviction
michael skakel related by marriage to
the kennedy family was convicted of
beating and stabbing martha moxley with
a golf club similar to one missing from
his family's home
prosecutors say too many witnesses have
died since the 1975 killing
and that they won't try skagl a second
time after reinvestigating the case
robert f kennedy jr believes he tracked
down the real killer
and even says he obtained a confession i
recently spoke with kennedy
here's how he explained one of skagle's
alibis about why
potentially his dna might be found at
the scene
he went over to martha moxley's house
and he climbed the tree
he thought it was her window it was not
it turned out it was on her window
it was her brother's window he threw
rocks against the window
and then when he could not get her he
masturbated for a short time
in the tree he didn't masturbate orgasm
he just said
he masturbated he then thought he felt
something weird and he scurried down the
tree and he ran
home so and the next morning mrs
oxley came to the house and came into
his room
and woke him up and said you know have
you seen martha she was looking for
martha because martha didn't come home
and michael said and he says this on the
tape
he said i thought she had seen me i
thought she saw what i did
he wasn't talking about her having him
worrying that she had seen him murdering
martha
he was that he was worried that he had
been seen masturbating outside of her
home
when jonathan benedict illegally got a
hold of that tape
michael had told this story to me many
times he told to many people in
aaa and many people who he was friends
with
and he told it to a writer in
massachusetts who recorded it
and then jonathan benedict who is the
prosecutor cut the tape
and put in all kinds of graphics some
kind of red blood pouring down it and
this kind of thing
and made it look like michael was
confessing
that he had been worried that mrs moxley
had seen him murder her daughter the
night before and that's what the jury
went away thinking
analysis right now so linda kenny budden
you consulted on this case
how did the prosecutor get such a
horribly doctored video
in front of the jury not only that aaron
i also did the hearings on the privacy
issues out of the elan school the
private school he was at
uh before mickey sherman actually did
the trial
okay so the judge allowed it that's how
it happened just like in every wrongful
conviction across the united states of
people that the death penalty the judge
allowed this outrageous tape at the very
end
that basically took the quote evidence
of which i will tell you there basically
was none
and argued inflammatory to the jury that
it had to be
the kennedy cousin who did this it was
outrageous it should have been reversed
right then and it should never be
allowed this kind of conduct by a
prosecutor in any court in the united
states
and terry you were on the side of uh
this case the other day basically saying
that you think the original conviction
was sound at least in your opinion
well here's what i think i think at this
point in time
it does not make sense to retry the case
i mean he was convicted in 2002
then he was granted a new trial and then
he was released and
then it was reinstated i mean i feel as
though
he has gone through enough and the
family has gone through enough do i
think he
probably committed the crime i do was
there enough evidence probably not
but at this point in time i do think it
makes no sense
to retry the case and brian the family
is basically saying that we agree with
the way the prosecutor's handling this
at this point
let's not do a second trial yeah i mean
that's how the family feels but
anything the prosecutor should have done
this the right way from day one
and the right way would have been to
have the proper admissible evidence come
in
and that video as linda is stating
should not have come in that audio tape
should not have come in sorry
and then then we would have found out
what justice looked like whatever but
i'm not guilty or guilty
but you have to do it the right way you
can't do it the wrong way here so linda
again
back to your assessment of this case
there was no dna actually found but
they got this statement out of skakel
because they said well
if your dna does turn up then
how would it have gotten there and
that's when he came up with a story in
the tree
well no he had told this story to a
number of people he actually had sodium
penetral tests he had
uh he had lie detective tests which he
passed early on okay
early early on before anything let me
just tell you let me just go
through this a second this was done by
somebody who was very strong she was
dragged 80 feet
she had uh it was a terrible terrible
crime um
there were slides of uh out of her
uh private areas that were lost there
was a hair that was dissolved by the
prosecution
when they were testing it there were
there were hairs
that were mislabeled there was a
fingerprint on the golf club which the
fbi said well they couldn't get a
fingerprint out of it but they didn't
exclude anybody
that somehow has disappeared there were
genes that was disappeared there was
evidence that was disappeared there was
nothing
that attached michael skakel to this
crime no forensic
evidence there was no eyewitnesses and
there was an alibi witnesses why this
case was overturned
who said an elderly gentleman who said
he was with him
watching tv at his house that mickey
sherman the original trial attorney
never ever even interviewed and that's
what a return for an effective
assistance of castle
yeah exactly that's what the connecticut
supreme court latched onto at least a
second time because remember the court
looked at it once
and then agreed that it was a sound
conviction then
new justices went and then new justices
on the court
flipped the case a fascinating case that
we will talk about for years to come
i'm sure and when we come back here on
law and crime daily
we take you to california for closing
arguments in the murder trial of a
former professional baseball player
accused of using a bat to commit triple
murder that's right after this
[Music]
the guilt phase of a trial involving a
pro baseball player and a bat
as an alleged murder weapon is wrapping
up in california
prosecutors say brandon willie martin
slugged his father his uncle
and a worker to death the worker just
happened to be at the family's home
installing a security system
from there they say martin stole the
security system company's vehicle
and led police on a chase that ended
with a k-9 officer biting the defendant
dex bit martin in his left lower shin
area
and did the suspect
respond in any way he immediately sprung
up to his feet okay
and what did he do at that point he
began
fleeing backwards through the backyard
and as he was punching dex multiple
times with fists
on his head and face at that point he
was
holding the bite and taking that punches
at one point brandon bent down
and grabbed the dog in a bear hug which
he had the whole dog's body his face
would be facing the dog's tail now
with his back towards his face and
picked him up
and this body slammed his whole weight
onto the dog smashing onto the concrete
the suspect bounced back up on his feet
now he was back up on his feet
dex was now biting one of his inner
thigh areas
he was latched on to the inner thigh and
not knowing what kind of damage the
punches were doing to the dog
or how much more the dog can handle um i
used my
rapid containment baton and two-handed
strike
struck him on his right shoulder
collarbone area on cross the k-9 handler
said the defendant was laying on his
back
staring up at the sky when police
arrived that testimony is slightly
different than that of the arresting
officer
officer jeans testified that when he
appeared around the corner
that mr martin was lying on his side
and that he could not see his face is it
your testimony
that he was in fact lying on his back
and staring up into the sky
yes and is it your testimony you were
able to see
his eyes when i said he's staring up
into the sky
it appeared eyes were open don't know
what he was looking at but eyes
are open that's my next question you
were able to determine that the eyes
were
open is that correct correct one time
you say
corona police show us your hands or the
dog will bite you correct
yes do you know was he able to hear you
i can't determine if you heard me or not
i would just think he didn't because he
didn't move
okay no reaction on the face
i saw no movement whatsoever didn't even
turn the hook to see
who was talking or what was going on i
don't i didn't see that
and when we come back closing arguments
in this case will a defense involving
drugs and psychotic
episodes spare the defendant or will
this case enter its next phase one which
could send the defendant to death row
we're back in just a moment
we're back with the trial of brandon
willie martin who's charged in a triple
homicide
the state wrapped up the guilt phase of
the case by saying the defendant
lost his baseball contract and turned
his anger and rage toward his own family
defendant with such power and accuracy
went for the head and hit the head broke
the head open
and haven't broken the head open went
back to the same spot
with such force that paint from that
bag embedded into the fractures
of michael martin's cranium
barry swanson had defensive injuries
you saw those to his arms as he was
beaten over and over
and over again the instrument of death
was not that baseball bat a baseball bat
that was
once the instrument of his profession
but you know that that was taken
and used to brutally beat
three men to death he left that back in
the hallway
and the name engraved on that
love soaked weapon
was brandon martin and that's because
ladies and gentlemen
brandon martin is the killer
the defense says martin's family was his
whole life and that he had no
motive to commit the killings
they weren't just going to toss him out
on the street
mr curse makes much of the fact that
miss brandon martin defied
authorities when one by being told by
ets he can't go home he defied authority
what is this young man supposed to do
is he supposed to join the homeless
population under the bridge
is he supposed to grab a shopping cart
put all his belongings in
and sleep in a bush at night because
what other options did he have other
than
defy authority by going home
folks he had no motive to commit this
crime because that was his entire life
the only thing he had was his family
hear you thinking i could feel the see
the wheels turning and saying okay
jensen if brandon martin didn't do this
who did
i don't know
and more importantly for the purposes of
your job
you don't care
those are powerful closing arguments
terry i thought just listening to them
now
yeah it was powerful but you know this
is a very tragic case
there's no question that martin had some
mental illness
he had had an attack against his own
brother broke his finger
he attacked his mother he had scissors
where he was going to use them against
her
so i mean i think this is a failure of
the system the fact that he
you know couldn't go home because they
were in danger
he should have been in a mental
institution he should have had a
diagnosis he should have had
treatment so something like this would
not happen again it's a very tragic case
yeah but terry is is that sympathy going
to result in a not guilty at this stage
he's gonna get a guilty um there's no
question in my mind just because
all of the evidence is totally against
him the only question is
will he he's not gonna get you know
death penalty we're in california
because you know there's a moratorium on
that
but the only question is will he get the
mental
you know care that he needs at this
point that's the question that i have
is he going to be sent to prison or is
he going to get
an institution that's going to help him
with his mental illness those are good
questions brian i got to ask about the
defense closing argument there because i
thought the defense
was really picking up traction there at
least to making a powerful argument and
then just said
well you know you shouldn't care i
thought it would have been better if he
said
it's not your job to determine that and
it's not our burden to carry it
yeah stylistically i think it was a
little off i don't think that i think
it's not powerful i would say
passionate is a better way of saying it
because he did come forward
in a manner that made you really believe
him but the question is believe him in
what
he led you to that edge of the precipice
and just kind of left you there without
kind of walking you past that threshold
and i think that was that's what was
missing there yeah i mean a burden of
proof discussion there i think would
have helped hey we're out of time here
on long crime daily thank you for
joining us we'll see you next time to
discuss justice
in america
[Music]
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions
we break down the case of a serial
killer another day of drama between both
sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the law on crime network is everywhere
and we invite
you inside the jury box this is lawn
[Music]
crime
[Music]
you